le diable se cache parfois dans les
détails et ce n'est pas Bruegel d'enfer
qui aurait dit le contraire Bruegel
d'enfer plus connu sous le nom de
Bruegel le jeune est un peintre flamand
du 17e siècle mais pas n'importe lequel
l'une de ses toits vient d'être adjugé
600000 € aux enchères un tableau qui
serait resté dans l'anonymat sans l'oeil
expert d'un commissaire priseur
d'Amboise Faustine
adjugé 600000 euros au téléphone
600000 euros et même 780
000 avec les frais d'acheteurs c'est le
prix auquel a été vendu aux enchères un
tableau du peintre flamand Bruegel le
jeune le 28 mars dernier à Paris une
œuvre découverte parce commissaire
priseur d'Amboise Malo de Lussac alors
qu'il effectue un inventaire chez une
famille persuadée de ne pas posséder un
original quand je me suis retrouvé
devant le tableau et qui m'ont dit
qu'effectivement c'était le beaugueule
mais que c'était une copie j'ai tout de
suite fait part de mon sentiment premier
qui était de dire j'en suis pas sûr
voilà mais je suis resté très prudent
passons alors entre les mains de
plusieurs experts le tableau est
authentifié et sa valeur estimée entre
600 et 800000 euros je m'attendais pas
effectivement une estimation aussi
importante que celle-là pour Malo de
Lussac c'est un beau coup de projecteurs
sur son étude puisqu'il s'agit de sa
plus grosse vente mais aussi d'une de
ses plus belles découvertes jusqu'à
maintenant effectivement cette
exceptionnelle de trouver un Bruegel de
cette taille là c'est quelque chose qui
est complètement inédit mais en fait
dans n'importe quel inventaire on a
toujours des petites surprises qu'elles
soient à hauteur d'une dizaine voire
d'une centaine d'euros comme bah d'une
centaine voire un million d'euros voilà
on arrive toujours à trouver quelque
chose d'intéressant sa curiosité et sa
passion pour l'art et l'histoire il les
a acquises de son grand-père qu'il
l'emmenait aux enchères lorsqu'il était
enfant cette personne avec un petit
marteau qui est du jet à des prix
hallucinants
je trouvais ce métier génial en fait
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui tient le
marteau un objet qui dans la profession
ne se prête pas c'est quelque chose qui
qui nous est très très personnel pour la
vente du Bruegel par exemple c'est ce
marteau qui a été quoi qu'il y a
officier et qui a tapé adjugé donc
j'aime croire aussi qu'il y ait une
espèce d'historique aussi sur sur les
marteaux un marteau qui devrait tomber à
nouveau le 28 avril dans la nouvelle
salle des ventes d'Amboise date à
laquelle le commissaire-priseur y
organise sa prochaine vente